yesterday was absolutely crazy we uh we
did like a five hour long show it was a
whole lot of fun and in the end the
Republicans did fairly well if you were
tracking the projections a month or two
before all this went down then you're
not surprised by the results if you were
tracking the projections only in the
week or two before you probably thought
they were going to do way way way better
and you know look I'll say everybody
wants to yell and scream Red Wave
because they want to boost Maria and get
everyone to go and vote but this is why
I I was saying things like don't don't
think you're going to win you need to go
out and vote no matter what the polls
say but in the end it's uh it's within
the parameters of what even 538
projections were up until like two weeks
ago when these debates started happening
so right now I think we're looking at
potentially 224 seats for the
Republicans in the house we're looking
at potentially 51 seats maybe with the
runoff we'll see looks like Nevada might
flip there's a few uh congressional
districts we're still looking at
potentially that are about to flip it
looks like uh in Maryland we may
actually see one District flip and then
uh what do you expect I mean Republicans
take the house in the midterm they can
launch investigations they were never
going to pass laws we'll see but Joe
Biden gave a speech Joe Biden came out
and said I will do nothing I will change
nothing
everything that's going as bad as it is
will continue thanks mostly because well
not a lot could have changed but because
Democratic voters they wanted it in
places like New York California this is
the thing that they want I mean I can't
blame them they live there they want it
by all means you can have it so we'll
talk about that and uh and so much more
we have a lot of election stuff to go
through DeSantis with his double-digit
lead uh winning in Florida now people
are suggesting that team he's he's the
front runner for 2024 and for the whole
presidency in fact and this story that I
just love Democrats voted in a dead guy
because they went in and they voted
Democrat and the guy was dead and I feel
bad you know my condolences to his
family or anything you know but they
voted for a dead guy so uh we'll talk
about that before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work we're going to have a
members only show coming up for all of
our members at about 11 pm which I can
only imagine will be fun and spicy so uh
go to timcast.com click the join us
button and you'll be directly supporting
our journalists and you'll get the
members only show and uh you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me at timcast and don't forget to check
out our new song over at losing my
mind.com we are currently now number
number 28 trending for music uh we beat
Shakira I think thanks in part to you
guys who are listening to our music
we're uh we're bigger and better than
the mainstream and we're going to keep
producing culture and and push back on
these establishment figures and take
parts of the space over with your
support so uh there you can see the
image of me scowling at Rachel Maddow I
love the video it's good fun seeing you
there you go joining us to talk about
this and so much more you heard him
laugh it's Mr Milo yiannopoulos
I'm I'm I've never been more petrified
any no no really I've been interviewed
by very aggressive intelligent and
hostile people
and you're of course a sweetheart but I
was just introduced I I have a greater
understanding of the restrictions under
which you operate now
um and I was I was sort of mentally
checking off as we talked about the
things that I probably shouldn't say
um I was just sort of mentally checking
off you know like oh okay that's uh yeah
so I I don't really have any ways to
communicate that don't aggressively
violate uh the rules of of the street of
YouTube and whatever but I've got I've
got Post-its
um I've made Post-its of the most
egregious offenses and and you know with
every good intention in the world I'm
going to do the best I can to be
socially acceptable for you but but I
want everybody hearing to realize that
we're going to do the members only
uncensored show and then you know we'll
show the Post-its and people by the time
that rolls around I'm going to be so
desperate to swear
um it's going to be very undignified
um like you know the reason we don't
like swearing is because people watch
what their their kids are in the room or
they're listening in the car and they're
driving their kids if you swear we just
you know ghostly child to be subjected
to political commentary could only
happen it could only happen in the third
world country
um civilized people are not so obsessed
with politics we have a lot to talk
about
um like with you and everything that you
that you've done and been going through
and what you're willing to talk about
standard form of child abuse
um
no I I look I'm gonna do the best I can
uh to stay within the lines that are
terrifying me but yeah I'm um I haven't
I don't think I've done an interview for
nearly half a decade
um wow because uh I just I just realized
that I didn't trust myself to color
within the lines well we're mostly going
to be talking about what's going on so
uh we'll get into it I'm very excited
about um this fetterman guy he's um he's
he's my new Fascination all right well
thanks for hanging out we'll talk all
about it we also got Luke here of course
this should be a very interesting show
I'm looking forward to it and they voted
in a dead guy and John Federman because
Democrat voters can relate to him
this is going to be a fun show but this
is why I decided to wear my normalized
critical thinking t-shirt which I think
we need more of than ever if you agree
you could get the t-shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and because
you do that's why I'm here Ian thank you
so much for coming where's the Hat I
give you a hat you're straight where is
it it's too too warm man I just wore a
sweater Milo you nailed one aspect of
communication that is that outfit it's
badass well I think it the flip-flops
are better I like it they're fish flops
I will show you oh fish flops if you
live in Florida for um any uh period of
time you begin to go native and you
start to wear things like this and
somebody got it from me is a joke and
they're the most comfortable things I've
ever had on my feet so I live
exclusively in crushed velvet handmade
slippers from uh German Street in
England and fish flops
um you know what I have I have I have
two thousand dollar like Versace uh
brocade you know uh sliding order I get
no compliments remotely close to how
much people love these shoes I get asked
I think 10 times a day where did you get
those shoes
um so yeah no I'm I'm basically living
the life of a of an eccentric retiree
which I'm happy with because because uh
it's it's I I do a lot of work behind
the scenes for people now
um so I get to I get sort of all of the
clout influence and income without any
of the stress of being in public it's
great the wild ride it seems terrible
yeah I I couldn't do it from 2016. I
have a better understanding now of of
the of the of the um a better
understanding now of the of the um well
expectations within which you have to
operate actually I have to say I
wouldn't be capable of doing it we
should this will be a really we should
have that conversation for the
uncensored show and just talk about how
the horse I should probably just talk
then
you'll have stuff to say so uh we'll get
into it we also got search press on all
the buttons hey what's up guys
sorry all right I wasn't trying to give
you a hard time would be it'd be
difficult I I just I don't really know
how to talk to normal people anymore
because I've just been a regular human
for five years
um you know so I I mean I I don't I
don't I don't know how to how to do the
um coloring between the lines thing yeah
it's an art form man it's a weird time
to be alive with uh social media
subjugation in a sense I don't think
it's ever happened in history Society
before like Ian wants to explain how to
make uh chlorine gas or whatever hey you
but does it doesn't does it have an
extraordinarily depressing effect on you
it must be tomorrow it does last night
the elect I wanted to say circulation
isn't it yeah it's like part of you has
been chopped off it's like my soul is
muted it's really disturbing and I want
to change well you're you're a
sweetheart so it's probably not so
difficult for you but but but those of
us who are compelled to break the rules
with every breath we take
um I think there used to be a place for
us you know California I I well I wanna
I think we can have a much greater
conversation on this for the uncensored
show but I'll just add I view it like
running through a battlefield where you
know Minds have been placed and we're
trying to make it to the other side to
win this conflict so also when you're
trying to change when you're trying to
change a system structure it's good to
go right next door to the system and
behave the way you want that system to
become and then it will bleed over into
the news let's let's say that let's talk
let's talk we'll agree to disagree on
we'll talk about that uh for the members
on the uncensored where we can go really
off but let's jump into this first story
ladies and gentlemen last night's
Republicans won and then I wake up in
the morning and all the conservatives
are angry they're saying that uh this
was a an unusable election and we did so
poorly and I'm seeing all these leftist
personalities cheering and screaming
like oh no red wave and I'm just like I
don't understand the Republicans won
like they won that they they won and
there's likely more winning coming I get
it Republicans wanted a bloodbath but
instead they got a victory so now this
is great Biden says he won't change
anything after successful night for Dems
doesn't tend to run in 2024 and it will
be fun watching Don V Ron taunts press
okay he's not going to change anything
that's not the message that people
wanted to hear the message that people
want to hear is things are going to get
better but things are bad and for a
variety of reasons people are willing to
vote Democrat and a variety of really
weird reasons like they voted in the
dead guy but uh I don't think people
wanna uh I think I think I think people
used to be engaged in politics because
they wanted to get a glimpse of a better
world but that's the that's the uh
washing powder uh version of politics I
think people are well into bitterness I
think people want to see the bad guys
bleed I I think that people want to see
that the bloodbath that you're talking
about right right comes not from a
desire to reimagine the world in a
better way because I think people are
losing hope in that I think people want
to see their antagonists suffer I agree
um I agree and the reason for the
Republican uh frustration is that they
were expecting a rare moment of
catharsis which is not granted often to
people with um right of central politics
a moment in which they could reassure
themselves that sometimes Justice is
done that the universe is capable of
delivering
um uh
True Justice where it is where it is
warranted and they were robbed of that
so they were it's what was stolen from
them was not
um some kind of uh uh you know um uh
washing powder commercial glimpse of a
better future what was stolen from them
was Revenge because these people don't
feel like they've been out of power and
that's a shame they feel like
um there are I mean they they articulate
their feelings now in very religious
terms uh and and they they talk about
their enemies in terms of demons devils
and Satan and the way in which they
express themselves
um you know and and the the uh the I
think the emotional the sunk emotional
cost that they had attached to the
midterms as a moment when they could
reassure themselves that maybe there was
um you know uh maybe there was still
some glimmer of but they won
well not really but they won what they
needed the house no they they uh what
what could they have done better what it
was it was a bog standard or slightly
unimpressive midterm in which the usual
swing occurred that is not what
Republicans were expecting right right
they were not what they were hoping for
that's not a victory
um when something happens that always
happens that happens whether you
campaign or not that happens whether you
do anything or not that's not a victory
that's um that says people perceive that
as a kind of
um as a sort of a um
almost like a weather event you know
it's just part of the natural cycle of
things there was no Victory because
there was nothing above and beyond what
what um the ordinary course of a midterm
election I understand what you're saying
that they needed something that proved
something symbolic and something they
just meaning they just wanted the people
who they feel are tearing their the
fabric of their civilization apart
um
uh doing all kinds of things that will
talk about in the uh no to to to suffer
they wanted to see their they wanted to
see the the
um I forget what the Conan quote is I
haven't seen it for 25 years but
um you know they wanted that
whatever the first time the Lamentations
were there women they wanted shrieking
they wanted the 2016 right right right
right they wanted let's see liberals
panic but that's that's that's nebulous
in the sense that by taking it no no no
no
fundamental by winning the house there
can now be inquiries investigation he
cares about winning the house right
right so so listen everybody cares about
winning the house so why Republican base
is now for them to forget elections are
here retribution for them to feel the
satisfaction is simply their choice they
got what they could get now I suppose
they wanted to see a tremendous
Landslide Victory they didn't get what
they did which wouldn't have changed
anything procedurally it would have felt
good no well I would just say I didn't
they didn't get what they could get they
were they rightly and hear it that they
were robbed of this Victory by people
who should have had their backs but
what's the victory what does Victory
look like they wanted to see their own
enemies humiliated right right and they
did and the only and they're not being
humiliated is because Republicans are
acting like they lost no no no
um what happened in this election was um
not only were the leaders in the
Republican Party removing spending from
some of the most inspirational and
popular candidates which itself is a
form of demoralization
um and sabotaging some of the candidates
that had the most promise for upsets
those little things that give you a
burst of magic in a burst of joy in an
otherwise uh um yeah
um
yeah I mean you know
he it would have been it would have been
nice if he'd won but
the what they correctly intuited is that
this was another example of the Republic
of powers that be in the Republican
Party leaving money on the table uh
actively sabotaging the candidates that
the base likes most because they hate
them and they are right about that
that's what happened
um the the powers that be in the
Republican Party sabotage some of the
candidates some of the candidates that
were the most popular with the base and
changed the result of some of those
elections uh through removing millions
of dollars in spending so the the
Republicans are acting out not because
they're um babies who are choosing to be
losers they're acting out because they
were wronged and they know it sure sure
but I don't think that that explains Ben
Shapiro for instance nothing explains
Ben Shapiro well look you look at the
daily wire guys and they're upset about
the results they're saying you know uh
to elect who has never had a moment of
contentment in their lives um so perhaps
that's it they weren't going to be
satisfied no matter what happened well
they weren't
[Laughter]
they won't be happy until a quite
different flag is flying over the White
House yeah but the midterm elections are
usually a referendum on the president's
term I think there's a reason why Biden
is coming out right now and saying I'm
going to be I'm going to keep doing what
I usually do but they they historically
politically are and if we look at
previous midterms like in 2010 and 2014
the Republicans overwhelmingly won by
huge numbers they didn't do that at this
time the Senate again it is still
undecided these results don't match how
people feel about Biden they don't now
there are candidates
um that
are weird special cases like fetterman
who has inspired sympathy and he's he's
just I kind of I can't sort of like the
guy
um it just brings out you know kind of a
warm feeling I just kind of want to see
him succeed because I see him struggling
and I see a fetterman
normal response to seeing somebody
um struggling is to want to help them
you know like I watched that debate and
I I wanted to vote for the guy
um that what people are seeing is
results that are out of step with how
they know people feel about this
presidency and the reason those results
are out of step is the Republican
leadership do you think who who took who
didn't just sit by and say uh let's just
let what happens happen
they actively sabotaged the chances of
some of the most popular populist
nationalist Trump adjacent characters
um it is and and you know voters are a
little bit better informed and a little
bit um more intelligent I think than the
Washington people give them credit for
um they have correctly intuited betrayal
they are not upset because the results
were you know they didn't get enough
seats they are justly
um incensed and indignant because they
know that they have been betrayed by the
people they pay to have their backs do
you think that the Republican Party
should split in half or split apart I
think the country should split in half
um I'm very much in favor of a national
divorce the Republican party is uh is is
an entity that survives despite failing
to understand how to talk like human
beings how to talk to human beings and
how to reflect the concerns of the
voters who out of you know the out of
the indefatigability of the human Spirit
keep hoping for the best and vote for
them anyway
um the party is not fit for purpose and
if it doesn't reinvent itself in Trump's
image um it doesn't deserve to live
Trump or Ron DeSantis that's going to be
the big debate here as well I don't
think anybody
um is seriously in favor of DeSantis
unless they're paid to be
I I strongly disagree with you on that
but uh that's gonna be a topic
you're on the wrong side
Megan McCain's side at all uh but but
more importantly here there is something
to say about this performance in the
face of economic inflation lockdowns
crime waves which seems like it wasn't
really affecting the election results
there's also the fact that a lot of
trump endorsed candidates didn't win
Trump's attacking some of them right now
and and the ones that he didn't be in
Canada and then the ones he attacked one
like here are some examples of that the
problem I I felt a bit um uh icky seeing
Trump whine about the Consultants it
didn't seem like a kind of Alpha Dog
daddy thing that we're used to from
Trump seemed to um a little bit pathetic
and uh my hope is that he will announce
soon and get his mojo back because
um at the same time as he's taking these
very light touch teasing pot shots at um
DeSantis who has zero chance of uh
succeeding um look DeSantis is almost as
popular as Trump in some bits of Florida
but don't ask them to choose because he
is gone the second they have to choose
between him and Trump don't don't get it
twisted okay
um he has no chance it is not happening
but you think in Tampa
Trump well Trump wasn't able to flip
those districts
you're out of your mind if you think
that
um somebody with the Charisma of a
potted Cactus
um can go up against Donald Trump and
not end as just another casualty on the
list
uh you're out of your mind and looking
at the
Rogues gallery of people who are being
paid to support DeSantis I think unless
you can provide a compelling case which
today I have not heard
um you are being charmingly naive in
falling in line with the worst people I
can give a very worse people in this
country uh
the worst people in this country who
want more than anything for the will of
the people to be subverted they want to
suffocate Trump and all he stands for
and he is of course merely a proxy he's
a he's um he's a shorthand for a variety
of things that they hate about Americans
they hate the ghostness of of of of of
the South they hate everything about the
south they hate um Appalachia you know
with its lack of sophistication they
despise whether and are contemptuous of
the people who love Trump and they are
The Architects of their misery I mean
there's a reason that the the the these
places that vote for Trump have drug
problems it's because the coastal Elites
systematically killed these towns by
taking all the manufacturing abroad to
weaken the economic uh um clout of place
of Republican places okay these places
were deliberately and systematically
sabotaged and the result of that is like
human misery on a scale that nobody
really truly comprehends there's now no
reason for many of these towns in the
South to exist and they stagger on with
no factories with no jobs with no hope
and people lose themselves in
godlessness and in drugs and in um uh
all manner of of
um of self-destructive uh behaviors
that was done to them that was that was
the thing that was done to them okay uh
and Trump is is a is a a neat shorthand
for the kinds of people that Coastal
Elites are considered to be beneath them
and the the DeSantis project is about
ensuring that Trump was a
temporary unfortunate blip never to be
repeated because they think they have
the right to determine that they think
they have the right to dictate that
um I don't think that's going to pan out
for them uh I think they're going to
continue to be humiliated
um uh just as they have been every time
let me ask a question let me ask a
question I would love to hear your case
for the sentence because absolutely but
my first question would just be if we
took Trump into santis and we made a
Venn diagram of everything they agreed
on where where what are the differences
that you see that DeSantis doesn't have
that what is that what is that X Factor
that Trump does have that you're talking
about
well you just said it um Trump is the
expert Trump is a once in a generation
um charismatic Authority
that cannot be replicated it cannot be
imitated uh
as somebody who has a little slice of
that kind of Charisma myself
um and has experienced uh retinue of
desperate clingers and imitators in my
life
um I can tell you it it never pans out
trying to you know uh
just snatch the bits that you can
stomach from the guy everybody loves and
otherwise keep serving your special
interests Trump is Trump is a
look whether you believe in God or not
um you could you could express this in
terms of ordainment if you wanted to
um you know or you could just say that
some people are born with a magical kind
of personality that captivates people in
a way that nobody else can can imitate
in terms of what people are getting
santis on the other hand has no
identifiable personality at all well so
sure um but but what what what
symbol policy feeling do people get from
Trump what victory you're making the
mistake that all politically minded
people make um which is assuming that
people vote on the basis of policy how's
that feeling
uh
DeSantis has scored some victories in
Florida he's been an excellent governor
in Florida and that's where he should
stay because he's been a very successful
and excellent governor in Florida but as
I said people like him in some bits of
Florida almost as much as they like
Trump but ask him to choose I'm trying
to figure out on the the gain people get
from Trump they don't get from DeSantis
and and that can be emotional it's
precisely that it's precisely that
magical intangible that
um you the the
you try to articulate and stumble and
then when you go to a rally you're like
that's what I was talking about
climatics man it's vibration it actually
Alters DNA uh I I don't know about that
but yeah change the way people's bodies
sounds like nonsense but
um that's amazing that's why music can
heal people and stuff uh no um
but um but but there there are people
who are born with that um gift and uh
they typically find some um uh way in
which to to express it but some of them
become singers some of them become
actors uh and saying Trump exudes really
Charisma doesn't
quantify what's happening for us in a
way that you know so so for me right it
does
mesmerizing I can't I get that you get
that but what what do so so a lot of
people are motivated intoxicant that
blots out the Sun what does a
conventional political candidate who has
a chance what does an intelligent
individual organized person gain from
that a good feeling I don't know what
kind of um logical fallacy that is uh
what does an intelligent person gain
well because you're saying the average
person doesn't care about I can't speak
for intelligent people but um so so if
no one actually cares about what their
politicians are doing for them then what
why should I care about Trump over
DeSantis Trump is
what Trump what happened in 2016 was
the last time that half this country
felt good about themselves and like
there might be hope
you cannot fight that hope for what
Trump what what what their world
wouldn't be ripped apart by uh social
engineering and by other things I can't
mention right now until the third hour
but
um there are things going on in this
country that that threatened the um very
basis of our civilization that stem from
original sins like women's suffrage but
go all the way through to more modern
fads and and manias uh to do with uh um
things we can't talk about but but
there is uh the the people are keenly
aware that
the
physical reality of the world they live
in the facts they took for granted are
being ripped apart by uh by the the
political descendants of um now I
understand I understand okay so Trump is
that Trump in 2016. I was very blessed
to have the opportunity to be such a big
part of that because
that was the last time that an entire
half of this country felt like things
might end up okay and he turned out to
be disappointing in office but how could
he ever have been any uh how could he
ever ended up otherwise
um not appointed really horrible people
around him like John Bolton and Dr fauci
and put him in positions of power that's
one of them but one thing I want to
bring Trump has a weakness for his
family I want to ask why is it very
difficult to say I wanted to his family
I think but but that's the answer to
your question the the reason that people
will will flock to him no matter what
even though they hate what he has to say
about
um uh certain medical things uh they
hate it they can't understand why he's
so proud of it they can't understand why
he never shuts up about it they just
want him to stop it's like do you know
who your base is bro
um but they'll forgive that and
everything because he was the last guy
that made them feel like justice and
hope so was was Within Reach I'll try it
I'll try and uh quantify it the way I
what I'm basically hearing is that there
are there are dark forces that are
destroying the fabric of this country
Donald Trump stood in front of that and
and put a fist up and said there might
it might not be too late
um that you know so so when Christianity
comes into Europe in the Middle Ages
right it's it's it's real Innovation is
um a sort of joy and happiness that's
not fueled by uh self-indulgence and
self-destruction so uh Pagan societies
you know um people losing themselves in
music and substances uh there's always
kind of a cost attached to that kind of
ecstasy right you get you get yourself
caught up in some kind of um uh hypnotic
Pagan uh um you know uh trance thing uh
the nearest cognate we have these days
is uh drug-fueled EDM raids it always
comes with a cost attached there's a
price to it
um when Christianity comes in the Middle
Ages you suddenly see like intensely
religious people singing and dancing
they found this way to be happy that
doesn't involve killing yourself uh in
some you know sort of slow motion
suicide
um people who are full of the joy of the
Incarnation and you have um you know
goggles pulling faces on on Cathedrals
you have religious people with smiles on
their faces
um one of the one of the
one of the emotional
capstones of Western Civilization is
that Joy
um you know another characteristic of
our artistic tradition is is yearning or
longing right most great works of art
are about reaching for something you
know about about that sort of romantic
frustration or whatever but but one of
the sort of the the emotional building
blocks of our civilization
um is joy joy in Christ um happiness for
its own sake
um
I don't think anybody could plausibly
claim that um society's getting happier
and more joyful what we've seen with
runaway um uh school now Michigan and
restrictions and regulations the kind of
um uh intolerable and oppressive
conditions under which some people uh
you know valiantly continue to labor
um
is a gradual suffocating of a joy
um
you know there's nothing recognizable as
comedy on television anymore
um and that and that well just just I'll
I'll be quick sorry
um that that that that
um
that gradual erosion of happiness
people feel that they're aware of it
they they won't articulate it in the way
that I did but they're aware of it and
they know that the last time that
something good happened
was this
crazy guy
that they remembered from a TV show who
suddenly
um suddenly inspired them with
confidence that maybe it wasn't too late
to beat back the hordes of hell yeah it
could be also the loss of religion and
the overindulgent society that is being
prioritized by big Tech social media but
when I want to specifically talk about
Trump because I did agree with a lot of
things you said specifically that he
does have a cult of personality he did
represent an idea that was going to help
the American middle class and it's a
demeaning um that's a that's a demeaning
minimization of the cult of personality
is a is a is never a compliment uh Cult
of Personality means that um somebody
has managed to baffle and bamboozle
their followers into doing destructive
things cult of personality is like baby
taking on a product I would say
shouldn't be taken that hasn't been
proven those operations
but I just want to specifically get to
the point of what happened today because
Trump's messaging doesn't look strong
today he came out and he talked about
how he got more votes in Florida during
his election he talked about how one of
his endorsements was wrong and he openly
threatened Ron DeSantis on Fox News
saying specifically that DeSantis is
going to hurt himself badly if he runs
and that he has some kind of dirt on him
that his wife doesn't even know that
he's going to release to the general
public this doesn't seem like a unifier
or someone who's going to bring the
party together and help the party
overall it seems like he's looking out
for himself even Picasso had a blue
period I mean Trump is Trump is
permitted a wobble given what he what
he's been subjected to he spent he spent
the past year just non-stop talking
about the past
I agree I agree and I think it's a
mistake yeah and I think that he
currently sounds pathetic and I think
that he needs to fix it real quick but
let me tell you the moment that guy that
gets his mojo back there isn't anybody
else on the field and and you best
believe that will happen that's a video
we should make you famous yeah
best believe that will happen um shortly
after he announces when he has kind of I
think emotionally reinvested in in the
fight but this is a guy who Art of War
this is like your enemies thank you
you're weak when you're strong right is
that what it is I don't know if Trump
thinks in those terms I don't know if
he's I'm only half kidding I don't know
if he's read a book but
um I don't know if he's read his own
um but he doesn't need to because he is
has that gift that a couple of people
per generation have which is well you
know when they're in a good spot and
they're uh and they're you know firing
all cylinders they just have an
atavistic uh reflexive natural
understanding of
um of of of of of their people you know
um and he's an interesting he's
interesting anomaly because typically
you see this in Europe where there are
more um uh explicitly established uh
class systems right
um so class operates in America but
everybody pretends it doesn't exist
which is why you don't really understand
half of what's Happening
um but
there's a weird Affinity between the
aristocracy and the working classes in
um European countries that retain some
Vestige of aristocratic systems and it's
and it's something to do with the fact
they live in the same places they both
live you know rurally in the countryside
they have some of the same Hobbies they
are involved in the same kinds of um
bits of the economy but they also have a
similar outlook on the world you know
they tend to be um uh conservationists
rather than environmentalists does that
make sense
um you know they they they've sort of
they have a kind of understanding that
the anxious middle classes the the
doctors teachers and lawyers who live in
big cities can't understand
Trump managed to pull that off in a way
that I don't know if any American really
ever has before Reagan maybe had a
little kind of dollop of it but not to
this extent Trump
perhaps because of his
um ludicrousness his uh putting his name
in gold on the side of his building so
on his plane the the sort of extravagant
and yet at the same time kind of
mid-brow mid-market version of opulence
that that he was showing people set him
so far apart from um or ordinary people
that he just managed to form this kind
of like weird but real bond in in in a
way I've only only seen previously in in
these you know in these um uh vestigial
class systems and and it's it's
something to do with the fact that when
he's listening to his own instincts
instead of um
certain family members and um uh like
Ivanka trunk that told him to bomb Syria
well her husband is the problem and
Jared Kushner who represents the
establishment and is tied to some really
seedy and and bad places and people well
Steve
um got fired for the same reason that um
I'm gonna get escorted out of here is
this finds it very difficult not to tell
the truth um uh so when he uh described
Ivanka as dumb as a box of rocks as soon
as I read it I was like yeah Steve said
that but this is my fear my life I just
want to bring this up really quickly
she's not she's not um she's not a
diabolical architect of her father's
destruction uh she's very easily
influenced
um uh a woman who's very in love with
her husband and anxious to maintain some
kind of social status independent of her
Father which means distinguishing
herself from yeah the views of his that
are unpopular with New York and I
absolutely agree with you but but aren't
you fearful that the establishment base
of the party has been kicked out or
prosecuted or is being currently put in
jail while the establishment wing of the
Trump Administration no the
anti-establishment is getting you know
thrown in jail has been kicked out has
been kicked out of his administration
and the pro-establishment side is still
surrounding him I don't think that um
whatever Petty humiliations visited upon
uh those brave enough to raise their
head above the parapet you know I don't
think those ultimately inconsequential
um humiliations
have much of an effect at all uh like
ivanka's there but Ben's not
yes look there are there are those of us
who are called compelled
um uh whatever whatever I didn't feel
like it it doesn't feel like much of a
choice to me just feels like what I was
put here to do
um to uh charge out in front and
um
accept the cost of that and what comes
with it you know uh and and those sort
of spectacles those moments in culture
those moments in history
um they linger for decades they have an
effect vastly
um uh more complex and far-reaching than
uh people usually appreciate uh you know
and when when
when people watched certain things
happening to
center-right popular funny guys
it will shape the thinking of Republican
voters for decades the fact that there
is a
that there is um for all of the Wailing
of the less left about systemic
Injustice which can never really be uh
located or convincingly
um explained there is
a a hideous Injustice that has been
visited on them and and many of the
people that they have admired and loved
that stuff shapes the way that people
live and the way they think it shapes
their opinions of of new players on the
scenes on the scene
um there will always be sacrificial
Lambs um that doesn't in itself
mean anything bad usually the opposite
um
Martyrs are remembered for a reason yeah
but do you feel finally do you feel let
down because you're one of the people
that was really behind Donald Trump so
were a lot of other people that were
censored that were punished that were
banned on social media and a lot of
people think that Trump was in a
position of power where he could have
stood up for his support or stood up for
all the individuals that were going down
taken down as he was in positions of
power do you feel like slighted in any
way where he could have done something
to Big Tech social media he could have
reigned them in and and he could have
also gone to parlor he could have also
stood up for free speech but but he
didn't I understand why a 70 year old
man might not have
comprehended the priority that that was
uh
look I watched the canceled Summit at
the White House and I noted like
everybody else that nobody who had
actually been canceled was invited yeah
it is a fact of historical record that
every year
um when the new interns came into the
White House they were asked if anybody
was a fan of Alex Jones or marianopolis
and if they said yes they were escorted
off the premises interns for Trump for
the White House in terms and you guys
were the big happened every every year
that Trump was in office now Trump Bears
ultimate responsibility for his hiring
decisions but the whole apparatus of the
party
was deeply committed to
a business model
that Trump threatened to wreck in in you
know in Insider generation the gravy
train might be over if he succeeded
um
the
the antibody response you know that you
saw to Trump
was the
aggressive ruthless uh sociopathic
response of people who are wedded to
Earthly uh wishes
seeing their hold threatened by somebody
who could you know cast a spell and
impoverish them uh
I wouldn't want 2016-17 to have played
out any other way
what possible better story is there than
of these people who were it's like you
know people were robbed of us it sounds
conceited to say but um you know this
this fascinating and exciting Corner
well it wasn't a corner it was was you
know culture really was sort of wiped
out by bad people with bad intentions
and no one was ever held accountable for
it and everybody feels poorer as a
result
um you know without cancer culture you
wouldn't operate under the appalling
conditions that you do I don't know how
you do it every day I couldn't I
couldn't get up in the morning
um and and I I that's why I don't I
don't wish for it to go any differently
than it did
um I think the lasting impression
and the righteous indignation that that
produced is one of the most powerful
motivating
um uh energies behind the Republican
base well what do you think about Elon
Musk buying Twitter and everything
that's happened so far well a sensible
person would probably say they're
cautiously optimistic
um the thing I've been following most
closely is uh his so
um somebody uh sent me a telegram
channel that just kind of catalogs all
of his activity on Twitter I don't so
much look at what he tweets because
that's obviously you know through the
lens of you know public management
whatever
what's more telling and where I think
everybody kind of gives themselves away
is in those casual likes that happen at
two in the afternoon or two in the
morning you know and the way he
brutally
um
handled Kathy Griffin
what I look for when I um when I'm
trying to kind of work out what what's
really going on I try to think what's
making this guy smile you know what is
bringing this guy uh happiness
satisfaction Joy
um because that I find to be a a
reliable indicator of future Behavior so
I'm looking at some of the stuff that
musk likes and I'm getting a bit more
optimistic
and then you know when he said um
she was in she wasn't uh she was
impersonated for she was banned for
impressing any comedian that's funnier
than anything that Kathy Griffin has
ever said that's true that's funnier
than her career and this tells me that
he takes great personal satisfaction in
seeing Justice served to those who have
been living high on the hog for far too
long
abusing and
um uh insulting uh
the rest of us while not allowing us to
respond in kind and that tells me that
he is
powerfully motivated to see Justice Done
publicly
so do you think that Kathy Griffin was a
good move or a bad move it's phenomenal
because it it it was
I mean Elon is the king of vaporware and
um and that's very frustrating but at
the same time he he has this sense of
theater and spectacle and
it was it was it it was it was
classically intelligent Elon because it
was just the right demonstration that he
meant what he was saying he put his
money where his mouth was he put one of
the most famous comedians in America in
the sinbin and then and then insulted
her amazing um and forced her to tweet
from her Dead Mother's Twitter account
which she then tried to play off as like
knowingly ghoulish but she just looked
weird yeah I mean she she's now I mean
she was she is a damaged figure anyway
um but she is a greatly diminished
figure as a result of this interaction
he didn't force her she decided to do it
herself which is disgusting in itself
she's well the mom thing was just kind
of like the the the
um clown World Capstone
the way in which he brought her to heal
by being funnier than she has ever been
which is supposed to be her job I mean
like who would go up against the
comedian on Twitter anyone because
they're not funny
uh because they're not allowed to be
anymore uh you know the basis of of
Comedy for centuries was laughing about
our differences so that we can realize
they're not that serious exactly that's
comedy right because because when you
when you point out in an affectionate
way
um amusing amusing ways in which you
differ from somebody else has the effect
of bringing people closer together not
driving them apart um and a deliberate
misunderstanding of this is behind you
know the death of joy that I was talking
about but
he chose just the right person who had
already damaged herself with the Trump
head and therefore it was difficult to
defend
um to demonstrate that he really meant
what he said and then in a final Act of
sadism which I enjoyed
um he said I guess if she really wants
her account back she can have it meaning
beg he said he said for eight dollars
thirty dollars yeah which is which is
great too you can say what you want
about me that's gonna be eight dollars
yeah um but but he he basically said to
her
I have humiliated you in front of the
world
you can come back but you've got to beg
me yeah
that's what I
in a sense was speaking for all of us in
that moment and and we were all kind of
like this is what we've been waiting for
and we got a little glimmer of maybe
what we felt in 2016. and and
it but but it was more than that it was
it was putting his money where his mouth
was right uh not that he hadn't done
that already but I mean I think he
borrowed most of the money for the
purchase but
um and put a lot of debt on the books
but who wouldn't uh
it was it was it was him showing us that
he meant it he actually did mean it and
and telling and and it was a it was a
standby and stand back or whatever it is
uh it was a just hold on I'm gonna deal
with this you made a very important
point about comedy healing society and I
think one reason why Society is so
ravaged is because comedy has been
pretty much been made illegal I remember
your your Patrick Ewing comment we don't
have to get into the specifics of it but
I remember it it just being hilarious
but specifically if you were given the
chance one more time to go back on
Twitter would you take it and how would
your
um how would you post differently how
would you would you be different or
would you be the same everybody I know
has had a very different uh trajectory
after cancellation to me
um
I I I'm sorry people are going to know
who I'm talking about and some of them
are friends and some of them used to be
friends but I've just seen people
um become just destroyed I've seen
people wreck themselves through this
like uh um
uh hysterical kind of manufactured grief
about a Twitter account it was never
that serious it was never that important
to me it was just one medium through
which I enjoyed amusing people but for
some people it was kind of all they had
um and many of those people have been
wrecked by this they're not the same
people they were in 2015.
um and and I I saw some of my friends
people I'd previously admired
doing this kind of you know pathetic
clamoring for some glimmer of former
relevance uh trying you know doing
anything at all costs to stay in the
headlines occasionally and I frankly I
felt that it was it was squalid and and
decrepit and beneath me and
um
um was absolutely not interested in
lowering myself to that uh so you know I
I think I've I think I've emerged from
it the most um psychologically uh intact
because everybody I know is was Driven
Crazy by it you know that um in uh in in
ancient Rome um when an emperor was
especially bad
um they would do something that was
later called damn nazio memorial so um
when the Emperor died they would chip
his name off buildings and smash his
busts
um uh with the goal of of erasing him
from history uh the idea was that you
know nobody would be able to tell in
future because you know in in Europe we
in western civilization we used to think
in terms of of civilization of legacy
yeah when when yeah when when uh when
the patriarchy was intact we
we thought more about that kind of thing
yeah um and and so the Romans were very
concerned about how um they would be
viewed in in future so when somebody was
especially cruel or Wicked or crazy
um they went to Great Lengths to erase
them from history
there's something
oddly more more sadistic and uh wretched
is happening now because people are
alive to see their own Erasure and
that's new in history there's no no
there's no real
um close equivalent to that it used to
have banishment
well yeah sure but but you know you can
go and you can make a new life but to be
but to be forcibly
uh
installed on the sidelines watching as
your name and your like and your work
and your reputation is destroyed and
dismantled and um urinated on uh that's
something that not even the most
sadistic and insane Roman Emperor
suffered
and I can understand why a lot of people
find it traumatic
um perhaps I I had a bit more of a
healthy attitude to all that in the
first place so I didn't kind of feel a
existential loss of like it's a Twitter
account oh you know and I still have my
house so I'll have my health
um you know uh I I I it didn't it didn't
you know it didn't you know make me wake
up in a cold sweat thinking I've lost
everything
um as it did to some other people
because I think I maybe had it a bit of
a better appreciation of what it
represented and what it didn't but but I
understand why they're why they're
traumatized you know
um it's been very it's been very
upsetting I personally would do nothing
different at all will you come back on
the platform I sorry that was your
question I don't know um I feel like I
mean I I kind of like
sort of Define that era and and me
coming back is going to be like a well
there's any all roads lead to some kind
of
um uh
some kind of um disappointing tribute
act to past glories you know and I don't
really believe in in in you know kind of
trying to resurrect uh past successes uh
I'm happy that they happened and and all
the rest of it but
I'm not somebody that can live that way
so I if I do it will probably be in a
very different format and a very
different style
um
I I it's a battlefield that I
comprehensively conquered
um and I don't feel the need to revisit
it because I beat it uh I beat it so
much that you know
they had to Institute um you know the
regime that followed they had a hashtag
uh I can't say the word they had to make
rules because of you they did I mean it
it set the trajectory for the for the
photo of the company you know
um and that's something I regard with uh
you know um Nostalgia and satisfaction
and I
revisiting it would be to fall prey to
um uh a a sort of debilitating
um temptation to live in the past I
found let me let me let me Rob you're
sorry Milo I want to ask you this
question because you talked about Legacy
and Roman emperors I'm wondering if you
think the loss of that in modern
civilization that we that many people no
longer care about their legacy and their
history is a defining factor in why
things are the way they are falling
because it's a product of women's
suffrage
um the kinds of people who were
plausible candidates for office changed
when
um the voting base broadened
and it's I don't think it's
controversial to say that the Sexes are
different and have different
uh priorities and different uh
preoccupations and different ways of
approaching the question who do I want
right
um
I I I'm of the view that women's
suffrage changed politics for the worse
because I think it opened the
um floodgates to uh opportunistic
Charming sociopaths who might previously
have been weeded out or considered not
the right kind of person sometimes you
see glimpses of this in I mean if you
watch Mary Poppins right and the dad
who's kind of like vilified
um Mr Banks is is the only virtuous
character in the whole thing
um and and he's talking about how
discipline order and an essential
English virtue restraint are the basis
of a of a well-function of a orderly
civilization
um and and those are the those are the
virtues the values the the um habits
that we should uh aspire to and all
around it he's got this
um he's got this uh pampered
um prideful mess of a wife who can't be
bothered to be a mother uh and it's
churning through nannies instead because
she's um you know got her whatever uh
there's there's this um witch who
descends from the sky and and you know
uh gives the kids psychedelic drugs I
guess
um uh we gotta remake this movie and
tell us no it's already down there
um uh you know and and um uh uh she she
kind of um wears the thin veneer of
rules and manners but really she
preaches chaos
um and she under and you know she she
under my [ __ ] there's stuff in that
movie that that is on purpose that uh in
um in uh feed the birds you know she she
she she has their audacity to claim
knowledge of what the Saints
think about uh you know Airborne rodents
uh pooping on Cathedrals uh damaging the
architecture uh it's it's a very
subversive movie about the Triumph of
Witchcraft over over a virtue but
um
you know uh is that what it is Mary
Poppins oh it's hideous it's fascinating
no it's very it's very dark it's very
dark um you have this you have this we
got to do we got like we have to do like
a thing where we watch it and you do
like a director's commentary kind of
thing where you explain there's a show
in Britain I think called gogglebox
where where the the show is two people
on a couch talking about the show
they're watching and it sounds like
unendurable but it's really good Bobble
box gogglebox I think I've never seen it
but but the but the um everybody
everybody loves it uh no I mean there's
so much in that movie you know to unpack
the way that she um she presents as as
um as a as an appropriate
um
uh candidate for the the role
um but then immediately sets about
wrecking the social order
um and it's a it's a particular kind of
uh
Christian restraint that um Mr Banks is
is is explaining he's you know he's
saying that we can't just give in to
every uh Reckless and wild uh abandoned
Temptation he's saying you know in order
in order to prosper and to be happy and
to be successful and to and for and for
our ancestors
um to be proud of us and our descendants
to be grateful to us
um there are virtues we should cleave to
um that involve not indulging ourselves
and what does Mary Poppins uh come and
do she comes in and and makes a makes a
mockery of the business of of tidying
the room by using witchcraft uh so
there's no effort expended
um uh violating the natural order of
things and teaching the kids that um uh
they can do their chores without the
effort required and therefore they don't
own lessons from it she takes them on
the Psychedelic Journey teaching them
nonsense words uh she uh Praises Praises
uh
um I mean you want to know this as
Americans but you don't feed pigeons in
London they're rats with wings that's
what that's what we call them you know
this this lullaby to to send people to
sleep
um is is is is about encouraging
um a Vermin that has destroyed the
architecture of London you know
everything in that movie is about um uh
undermining or overturning uh the the
natural order of things and this is this
is what uh the
headless selfish prideful mother wrapped
up in her own political
um escapades neglecting her duties as a
mother uh is engaged in she's engaged in
the Brazilians now the reason that that
I uh abhor women's suffrage is not that
it was uh something women just demand
demand demanded that they don't deserve
or that they're not capable of executing
actually it was a a manifestation of
cowardice from the men because it was a
way of saying you're on your own handle
yourself I'm not responsible for your
decision making and therefore I can't be
held accountable for what happens yeah
afterwards women's suffrage was a result
of a crisis of confidence in the men
um and this was greatly in Houston and
um and concentrated by the two world
wars that Europe uh uh experienced where
men I think basically
um lost the uh
they felt like they lost the right to
rule uh they felt like they'd wrecked
the world I mean it's difficult for us
from this distance to appreciate
the unfathomable you know Psychopathic
horrors of the Third Reich you know uh
in whatever manifestation you choose to
believe you know whichever
configuration of historical fact they're
all terrible
um
how a well-ordered Christian Society
gets to the point of going along with
that is something that ought to haunt
all of us and it haunted everybody
um because people like had friends in
Germany and they're like how could you
send your kiss to Hitler Youth Well
everybody's in the hill Earth it's just
like the scouts the the way that that
country got swept up in it it's
something dark and dangerous about human
nature that we are yet to really
understand it's the obsession with
religion as an institution that's really
done Christianity dirty man to say that
it's out there and if I think those
things then I don't have to live like
Jesus was you got to live like Jesus
that's your job as a Christian then you
in you embody the Christ that's all we
need well I'm Catholic so I can't agree
with your uh heretical opening um but
but certainly we should look to Christ
as an example to live by
um but you know Christ is not um Christ
is not an emotionally incontinent person
in the gospels I don't think he ever
laughs
um he's quite a serious guy and
says quite outrageous things things you
couldn't say on YouTube and
he is actually quite a profoundly
serious figure despite the Great Joy he
brings into the World by his uh his his
selflessness his sacrifice but very
interestingly
what he what he lays down for us
um is what became you know the great
classic English virtue of restraint it's
uh I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna say no
because I I understand that there are
consequences that come with short-term
pleasure and this really is the most
useful lesson that anybody can teach
their children and Mary Poppins is a is
just an extended
um uh it's an extended
undermining of the most valuable lesson
that any parent can teach their child
yeah and when you look at modern
entertainment you do see a lot of those
themes regurgitated and exaggerated
especially
yeah it's unwatchable because it's not
entertainment it's propaganda a lot of
it is is sometimes if we're lucky it's
subconscious and subliminal but many
times it's overt in your face the larger
messaging of not just degeneracy
short-term Pleasures but but just also
destroying not only race relations
sexual relations but destroying kind of
humanity from the inside with this
psychological Mass hypnosis as I call it
the individual all subject matter are
all you know arguable and and will
probably agree about all of that but the
real characteristic that it that it has
um the way to understand it because it's
happened before in history
um the the nature of its character it's
nature is that we're entering a late
decadent period of gloating that is
common to all um illegitimate materials
uh and the one we have right now is
something that Orwell didn't foresee a
weird blend of private Enterprise and
government
um run by the same people
um who operate both for their exclusive
enrichment and which has impoverished
all of us in spiritual ways in financial
ways in all kinds of ways uh culturally
you name it in in every conceivable way
our lives and our society are getting
dramatically worse with each day that
passes and and my decision personally
has been to refuse to play along with
that and I won't operate within those
rules because I think it's um
I think it's beneath the Dignity of a
human being to do so
um I don't mean that as a I don't mean
that as an insult to you guys because I
I admire the discipline that it takes
and I I understand the calculus that
you've made right we're gonna we're
gonna say less but to more people I
totally get it um and and there's
there's a there's a spectrum on which we
all operate I'm on the opposite end to
you guys so um you guys and I have taken
a different strategy to the same problem
um both are right and both are needed
you know I just you know we just we just
are on opposite ends of it
um but the the this this late this
gloating the um the gleefulness with
which they um Revel in their
unaccountable and untrammeled power over
us is intolerable and unsustainable and
when that happens
um in history the empire in question
typically Falls really quickly shortly
thereafter and when big nation when big
Empires fall they don't fall like you
think they're going to they don't kind
of ossify they don't um disintegrate
they evaporate uh it happened to Rome it
happened at the USSR and it will happen
to America the the yeah
the vector for America is probably going
to be the Petro Dollar in the Dollar
General I I asked you about uh the the
loss of I guess we don't care about
Legacy anymore or at least many do but
many don't it's a shift in priorities
from the widening of the lecturer right
right actually you mentioned this I want
to specifically go in in that direction
you're saying that women don't care
about Legacy as much as men do or what's
the what's the how does that how does
that happen a system working perfectly
um is a system where everything is in
its right place uh performing the
function for which it was designed okay
and if any if any component in that
system is improperly utilized or damaged
or in the wrong place the whole thing
can seize up and sometimes it can it can
be destroyed a fine watch from a Swiss
watchmaker will be uh
irretrievably wrecked by a component
being moved from here to here you can't
you can't fix it
only they're very expensive ones but you
get the point
we I take the same view of creation
um we ought not tamper with um
uh
the order that has been laid out for us
and there are different distinct
um equal bit different I suppose people
want to say
um there are distinct I don't think they
are equal I think women are greatly
venerated and always have been
um and when women ask for equality with
men I I'm of the view that they are
silly in asking for a demotion
um
what we shouldn't tamper with is the
proper order of things there's a proper
order to the physical world to the
natural world that reflects the Heavenly
order that represents the supernatural
that reflects the supernatural right
um it's an echo of it and when we have
men doing things that women should be
doing and women doing things that men
should be doing and when we commingle
the definitions of those two things
um we risk the whole system falling down
and I think that's what's happening I
think that's what we're witnessing uh
and Camille Paglia the uh feminist
critic
um says that uh the one characteristic
uh an infallible guide to imminent
collapse in
all great civilizations in the past is
an obsession with uh she calls it kind
of gender Madness right
um without getting into the subject uh
uh in in in a way that would be
dangerous
um
a preoccupation with um Innovative and
sometimes confusing new definitions of
things they're sort of confusing of this
fundamental natural this is the moment
at which civilizations lose their way
and they don't last long after that
so um I think that um it is a man's
responsibility to protect and to provide
I think that um men go out and create
all these extraordinary things
ultimately to impress women when men
want to impress other men they take
creatine and work out that's always for
other men uh women don't care about
about physics so much that's always for
for men
um something sort of intrinsically
homosexual about that but
um when men go out and and Achieve these
great feats uh building civilizations
you know constructing Cathedrals so it's
um it's because they want access they
want in and they want to you know that
that it's a it's a it's a romantic
project
and
it's beneath the Dignity of
of wives and mothers
uh who have a far more important purpose
on Earth to
give them you know the petty workings of
these political experiments that men
have come up with to occupy themselves
um to to to you know distract them with
that stuff and and I don't think it's
something that um women especially love
I mean women kind of hint this uh sort
of they send us subtle indications that
this might be the case
um you see very often women kind of
adopt the politics of their husbands uh
it's kind of a phenomenon that
um uh is actually it's actually more
pronounced the more extreme that the
husband's politics are so you have um uh
you have these these women who fall in
love with like jihadis and they adopt
you know radical Islam and then they go
husband surfing because their husbands
all you know kind of do suicide bombings
um they Bounce from husband's husband
but they start off you know like
perfectly normal uh Jihad Jane Jihad
Jenny there's a Samantha loose weight
loads of examples of this women who just
kind of adopt any politics at all uh to
get the guy right and this is their way
of telling us that they don't really
care you know it's just like they have
other priorities they want to feel safe
they want to feel secure they want to
feel loved to provide you for protected
and part of doing that is um is sparing
women from
the ugly
baffling and frankly squalid world of
politics full of opportunists and freaks
and inappropriate people you know
they're all the people who want power
right the people in politics uh and so
we we suffer them we you think women
shouldn't be in politics
um I think that in America because
American men are so
um
are so utterly pathetic
um uh all talk and no action that when I
find American women much more impressive
than American men and there are lots of
examples of women having to step up
where men have left vacuums I think
Marjorie Taylor green is an example of
that
um she will readily readily tell you
that in a perfect world she wouldn't
have to be doing this but she felt that
it was necessary and that she was the
right person the right time
um because because no man is doing it
for her so so I see her as a as a kind
of um a sort of a buddhica uh Joan of
Arc kind of a warrior Queen archetype
you know she's doing the thing that no
man will step up and do and you know
every couple of hundred years men need
to need a reminder like that that
they're um uh uh that they're renewing
on their responsibilities uh I don't
think it's the proper Arena of women to
to concern themselves with uh you know
the the intricacies of politics uh
because they have a higher and Holier
and much more important purpose
um to which their skills are better
suited and I I think that when you when
you know when when in in the two world
wars and women flooded the mock the
workplace out of necessity uh and then
you have you know they mention the
washing machine which frees up this
enormous amount of time
um
once women had been well uh pleaded with
to to come and keep think keep the the
factory Line running uh nobody felt they
had the right coming back from War when
they direct the world to say all right
back in the kitchen love
um so so they just sort of accepted the
new the new reality
we can see what's we can see what's
happened as a result there's there's
been a feminizing of our institutions
police forces have started to act more
like School teachers where they're kind
of scolding people for using the wrong
language rather than uh uh you know
criminals there's all kinds of hints
that the priorities that the mission
statements that the uh modus operandi of
our of our state institutions and and
now private Enterprises too have have
changed and I I don't think for the
better uh as a result of of um
what was Miss sold to women as
emancipation and was actually their
enslavement would you would you advocate
for repealing the 19th Amendment
absolutely
for those I don't know it's the women's
right to vote we owe women
um an enormous apology for the
imposition that we placed on them
um by this Grievous ongoing offense
subjecting them to the ugliness of
politics when they should be concerned
with uh raising the Next Generation and
and perpetuating the dynasty which is of
course the thing that the man is
worrying about and finds it you know he
finds a wife that he believes will be a
partner with him in that Pro in that in
that task
um and while he's having these grandiose
uh um thoughts and and building these
extraordinary structures it's the women
that are doing the hard work of raising
the Next Generation they can't do both
um and I think now we've seen in women
are beginning to admit in columns in the
Atlantic and elsewhere that they
couldn't do both and they wish they'd
done the other one why do you think this
is happening I mean there was a big Push
by the industrialists individuals like
David Rockefeller that wanted to of
course make sure wages were lowered make
sure that there was a bigger tax base
there was a political push a
psychological psychological push but
there's also a biological push if you
look at men their grip strength is going
down women's grip strength is going up
Men's testosterone is going down their
sperm levels are going down reproduction
rates are going down family units are
going down there's a lot of different
things that we could attribute so
delicious but I think I could read no
don't you mind though how dare you I
will so much right I will drop dead
because of Code Red I will you probably
will it will be the thing that kills me
I will guess I will be so fat I don't
know if those rumors are just urban
legends or whatever but I want to get
back to this question here is what is
responsible for it and and how do we fix
this overall problem how do you see the
how do you quantify the problem how do
you fix it so um capitalism
um wants maximum freedom because maximum
Freedom means maximum profits uh and
that works on both the supply and and
um but it works at every point in the
chain right so the more workers you have
the better the more people who can work
the better because the more diverse a
Workforce is is the less likely they are
to unionize which is why big businesses
in favor of diversity because it makes
their workforces easier to abuse and and
to manage that's the reason big business
likes diversity because if you have a
Workforce made up of people who can
barely speak each other's languages they
are never going to get together to beat
the boss well let me add to that too
when the rules are so uh atomized you
can get someone in trouble for anything
anybody who is acting out of line you
can say oh well you're violating this
provision this I believe is a
manifestation of a frustrated maternal
Instinct from women who should have had
children and didn't and it's become a
sort of um uh it's become this kind of
out of control turbocharged policing of
others this attempt to impose uh order
on uh um on the world
um and and you know I I lay the blame
for this at the feet of men who um you
know it's it's the job of a husband to
establish the parameters within which
his family will operate these these are
the things that I will accept and these
are the things that I will not accept
and and he counts on his partner to
express those wishes in her daily
decisions and how she raises the
children
well men haven't been doing that for a
really long time
and the result has been Anarchy
and not just like not just chaos but
like true epistemological Anarchy
they're they're like multiple fact
universes in America now there are
people who believe completely different
pictures of what they think are as
objective reality right because instead
of politics being
um a a you know the art of the possible
grounded in reason now we have
um competing narratives and these
narratives are are completely factually
divorced from one another and in most
cases from from reality themselves as
well this is the result of um this is a
feminization of discourse because we
become untethered from Mr Banks's reason
and discipline which always falls on the
man to uh to to hold the line and
instead we begin to indulge in um I mean
to put it in grammatical terms right uh
women live in the subjunctive they live
in the world of the possible right uh
and they the the the economy of value
for women is completely different than
it is for men
no man really understands until he has
explained to him why women like
expensive handbags so why do you want
this thing that costs five thousand
dollars it's not worth five thousand
everybody knows it's not and what he
doesn't understand is that the price
point is part of the future a feature
set for a woman because when she
exhibits this handbag to others she's um
signaling that she has snagged a high
status husband that she's secure that
she's safe and that she's part of
um uh an ongoing and secure Dynasty that
will outlive her and that she has
acquired a secure and enviable position
in the pack in the social packing order
and that social packing order you know
is a preoccupation of you know the the
parish uh you know
um scolds of popular Legend uh
men don't understand that um
buying the big diamond that makes no
sense because uh the the association
with diamonds and Eternity and lovers
and eventually ad industry right like
yeah it was a scam it's it's a it's a
complete confection but it's meaningful
now and it matters now
um because it's an expression of
something that
women want to see in their husbands is
um that they will do anything the grand
gestures the romantic gestures even
where it imperils their own um uh
pleasure well-being to demonstrate
publicly demonstrate their love for this
woman right and then they want to build
a home with a man who they don't
necessarily always agree with but they
always admire and respect and they they
the deal is I'll do what you say even
when I don't agree with you because I
respect and admire and trust you enough
to let you set the parameters for you
know for the for the the household yeah
when men fail in their duties to set
those parameters women expand endlessly
with no limits and we see that in in in
in in HR departments I mean the reason
that people like me can't get Podcast
deals is that the ad sales department is
entirely feminine uh it's it's 100 women
um and so so the vice president will be
like I love you I just can't get these
women to sell you to advertisers because
they're going to come up with a bunch of
reasons why you're whatever
um the the economy of value is so
completely different and and you know
when people stray into areas that are
not the proper domain and that could be
a husband interfering in some thing that
happens domestically
um or it could be a woman in a in a
conventionally male sphere
it's a trap it's an illusion it seems
that first like Freedom emancipation but
actually it is enslavement yeah just to
really I agree down a lot but I
disagreed on one thing I don't think
it's it's related to Anarchy I think
it's related to centralization
especially when it comes to things like
the ESG score that has been pushing a
lot of these social norms on to people I
I think you know the industrialists the
governments especially with the policies
they put forward the initiatives that
they put forward and what they do and
what they incentivize truly has been
leading to a society that is creating
more slaves and the state having more
power there's a centralizing tendency in
uh matriarchies because they're trying
to recreate the patriarchy that's let
them down
um they're trying to recreate the um the
the the patriarchy that that failed them
by by disappearing right so they're
trying to recreate it except they don't
know how because they don't have the
tools right just like you know this the
reason Satan Rebels and because you know
becomes Lucifer is that he is driven mad
by jealousy because
God gives women a gift that Angels don't
have
and it's the gift of co-procreation with
God right when you within the holy
sacrament of marriage are blessed with a
child you don't just create a child with
your husband but you are co-creating
with God because while you produce the
biological matter God imbused that child
with an immortal Soul so in in that
Sacrament your husband and wife are
engaging in the Act of Creation
alongside
their Almighty father
like extra like you know we talk about
forever but but
the Angels didn't get that
um and and driven mad by jealousy and
and rage at um what he saw as the sort
of preferred younger sibling um this is
the basis for for the Rebellion right
um that should that should frame our
understanding when we talk about this
it's not that we think that women are
are stupid or incompetent clearly they
can manage perfectly well in these
spheres whether the effect is good or
not you know is is another matter but
clearly they can they can handle it
um
but it's allowing uh encouraging them or
enticing them to do so as big business
does because it's good for the bottom
line
it is only possible when you set to one
side
the reality of the the magic and
responsibility an Incredible Gift that
women have that we don't I thought that
was really uh I guess inspiring what you
said about
Society kind of becoming overly mothered
because women aren't having enough
children and so they're turning that
motherly Instinct outward it's got to go
somewhere they're built for it they're
built for it and and if they choose if
they if they are lied to and choose
their career over um having babies
it has to come out somewhere so what do
they do they end up in HR where they get
to make rules just like they would if
they were a mom this is funny we uh we
we talked about this because there was a
story we read and I mentioned that there
are some women not all not most but
there are some women we see posting on
things like Tinder that they wish they
just were able to have families and
didn't have to have careers and The
Young Turks took that and turned it into
Tim Poole thinks all women or some like
Temple's ridiculous argument about women
it's it's it's it's fascinating that you
can't even acknowledge that some women
feel that way there's a there's a
there's a counter-intuitive
um but inescapably true uh fact which is
that the Freer women have gotten the
more miserable they have uh become well
how about uh just one quick point in
Sweden where women have more equal
access the gender differences are
actually more pronounced yeah
um because people are so desperate for
them uh
you can you can neatly uh trace the
history of women's emancipation
um and it tacks directly on to
um how women report their own increasing
misery and also the anti-depressants use
and also big Pharma tablets ssris
antidepressants which have gone up with
that unsatisfaction one in ten Americans
on um on on antidepressants uh half of
all Democrat women so they've been to
the doctor for mental health problems
um you know that's that's that's not
normal and it doesn't happen elsewhere
in the world it doesn't happen in other
places yeah we medicate their misery and
and yes and this is well we we the
pharmaceutical model of mental health uh
is only capable of treating symptoms uh
it can't fix what's wrong with you
because it doesn't account for the
existence of a soul at all it treats the
body as a purely uh mechanical
um uh uh machine as a machine and if
only we could find out which bit needs
more oil or which bid is needs replacing
we can fix your depression well that's
not the nature of depression uh that's
not the nature of of most mental
illnesses
um we just recently discovered finally
that the um uh psychiatric industry
admitted that there is no basis for the
um for the
accepted wisdom that depression is a
chemical imbalance they can't find it
they can't prove it so it might be that
depression is a product um maybe of of
guilt about uh about Sin that has not
been
um that no Absolution has been sought
for of terrible things about all kinds
of possibilities let me open up but but
the the current system is is is totally
incapable of of healing it's only
capable of um dealing with the symptoms
placating in a way that produces new and
worse problems like addictions yeah I
mean the the the the the the range of
um temptations that are uh available so
we don't understand addiction very well
because we don't understand the brain
very well but the one thing we do know
is the uh the the main difference
between people who relapse and people
who don't is is it available is it right
there right so people who stay away from
um you know from the junkie uh uh
Hangouts all the rest of it it's not in
front of them so they're less likely to
relapse uh if the that's the the one
thing we do know about it right
we are force-fed I mean this country's
Force feeds people with
a bewildering array of uh potential
addictions whether it's to compound
interest or um uh um
competitive uh sort of consumer purchase
TVs cars I mean none of you own your
cars none of you own your car I've never
bought a car in any way other than
outright and in cash
um and in this country people burn money
uh jumping from car to car like saying
goodbye to 20 grand each time and making
endless repayments that will never be
fully paid down I mean your whole life
is enslaved to interest to to people who
don't do anything for for
um for the money they make which is
usury which is a sin
um you know people who are entirely
parasitic I mean the basis of um the
basis of value in the economy is human
labor right uh it's people doing stuff
um these industries that are uh designed
to profit uh without effort there's a
reason that the church you know uh
regards this as Sinister and sinful
because it is
um and and
the the the the manner in which we are
presented I mean you know I think that
mostly what people said about video
games in the 80s and 90s was stupid and
what people said about Marilyn Manson
was like pretty stupid
um but the religious right was was
pretty bang on about everything else now
however when you consider as part of the
overall kind of junk food
drink prescription drugs I mean
I can't it's it's a wonder that I mean I
think every every American basically has
two of the of the ten categories but but
wrestling you know it's not normal it's
not normal yeah this is this is an
abusive relationship
um and and I and I have so I'll be quick
I'm sorry I'm sorry um the the in in
just the same way that many of these
cultural problems have come from women's
suffrage
um the failure of the institutions to
protect people is a result of American
independence because
when you throw away
the monarch
you don't really just get rid of him you
make space for something else to move in
uh and you might not have control over
that so America is now in a position
where they are ruled more brutally and
more savagely and more abusively than
any Monarch in living memory anywhere in
the world but they don't know the names
of the people who are doing it to them
central banks and they deserve that's
for sure certainly there are certainly
they're a part of it but what instead
you have is the empty Pomp and
Circumstance of the Fourth of July this
Rippling flag
um why do you love the flag so much
because there's room to hide behind it
and the people who are really running
the show whose names none of us will
ever learn
um are are what moved in
um instead of okay instead of having
okay and and you know people will differ
on this very violently I appreciate that
I'm probably taking minority view on
this but
um when we when we think about how the
Earthly order should reflect the
Heavenly order
um that that's the that's the the sort
of basis legitimacy of the papacy and
the monarchy right
um the way that societies are are
ordered
um reflects the Heavenly order and come
and conforms to Nature and the way that
and our nature the way that we would
design the way the way that we work
um and those are the best and happiest
systems to live under they work the best
I the the
removal of the Monarch from the top and
then these kind of weird self-sabotaging
things like we're just gonna
we're just gonna trust that everybody's
gonna be Christian so we'll Outsource
morality to Christianity and we'll give
people these extraordinary freedoms that
don't exist anywhere else
um that wreck Society unless the whole
population is christian right you cannot
give people the first and second
amendment unless they're Christian you
just can't because only with that kind
of um uh incredible reverence for the
Secretary of Life can you trust people
with weapons of war
um and only with the responsibility that
comes with knowing that you have to go
to confession for lying can you be
trusted with uh freedom to say anything
about consequence I agree with the with
your statement on second I think that
the founding father's perspective on
society dictated their view of why
everyone should be armed they trusted
each other they they all thought each
other had some uh fear of doing wrong I
just don't think they anticipated that
the society would become Godless uh I
think you know we're talking about 1700s
right uh I mean you're you're living in
the
um you're living in the wake of the King
James Bible which changes everything
because it's
uh it's you know people people sometimes
try to like demean it by saying it's a
you know greatest work of literature in
history which is you know true but stop
um the way that the the America's
founding documents are phrased and the
way that the founders spoke is
um heavily heavily influenced to the
point of dictated by the language and
the style of the king of the King James
Bible which came out in the early 1600s
right so when this this country is
founded in the wake of this
extraordinary
um moment unique in the history of ideas
where one book like changes everything
and and sort of uh uh defines everything
that follows it
I don't know did they ever imagine I
mean when they when they enshrined
freedom of religion they were thinking
about just like making sure that
Protestant denominations weren't at each
other's throats they weren't intending
for uh ilhan Omar to come in and say
some people did something and for her to
be uh uh sitting in Congress
um allegedly from a family involved in
very ugly things in her home country of
Somalia um uh she couldn't possibly have
sought election in this country for uh
virtuous reasons I can't imagine what
they would have been
um this is not what was intended and
that's you know this ugly phrase
Christian nationalism um that uh people
are are so afraid of what it really is
is um my view is uh is is a restitution
of the original vision for America but
with a few more safeguards in place
um so it's it's a it's a acknowledgment
that this country doesn't work without
Christianity uh it falls to pieces and
it is falling to pieces um thanks to
godlessness why because those
understandings of the proper places and
roles and functions of things aren't in
the law anywhere the existing common law
and in Tradition and in custom in Europe
but this break this rupture that happens
with this Edition and the and and
getting rid of the king resets a clock
in America and there's none of those
things to draw and just trusting that
people are going to stay Christian and
therefore be nice to each other was
stupid
I one thing I I don't necessarily agree
with is that or what there's a statement
you know we're made in the image of God
the universe is like we're like fractals
of reality so like there's one God hence
one Monarch and that is that now many
Christians who talk about fractals of
reality oh it's just scientific you know
observations you do a lot of LSD not a
lot but I have a little bit yeah keep
your dosages low enough to stay sane my
friends my a very dear friend of mine
who's a very gifted photographer does um
uh little micro doses of LSD and he has
a similar similar phrasing to you oh
cool um well what I'm thinking I see
that you see everybody thinks that they
have this um extraordinary unique
experience that turns them into a genius
but they all sound exactly the same I'm
just kidding I'm sorry uh Carol oh so
there's one God that I I agree that
there is in in one sense one overarching
magnetic field or whatever the hell God
is but then there's also within that it
can be broken down into Infinite Gods
all infinite Fields creating one Mega
field so in that sense we could have one
king or we could have a decentralized
system of many many local leaders I
think you've broken your brain well it's
two ways of looking at this one this
sounds like astrology for men
um you the what LSD does in creating
those new Connections in the brain which
produce the um you know moments of
inspiration is uh it disorders the uh
established Pathways and while it's
thrilling and exciting and can make
people sound very interesting uh it also
gets in the way of um
critical thinking because your
there's there's a sort of um people have
done a lot of LSD they have this
infatuation with this way they see the
world now they think they've got this uh
um Insight that nobody else has uh into
the nature of reality when actually
um they're just confused by a bunch of
things being stuck together have you
done LSD uh no mercifully not you should
do it before you talk about it I uh I
don't need to kill someone to know
murder's wrong no um there are things
there are things that I'm happy to trust
that I shouldn't try and and you know
that that's um that's another another
that's another thing about women's
suffrage is um it's a kind of violation
of the Innocence of women that Menace
are attracted to I mean the the soil
that nourishes that protective instinct
is the is there Purity and innocence of
young women who are unsullied by the
ugliness of the world you know
um and and uh
men can go out and be uh Reckless and
wreck their brains and and uh and uh you
know make make terrible mistakes and all
the rest of it but but when you when you
inject women into a sphere that um that
they're not created to flourish in
um it does something
uh inexcusable to them it is an
imposition on them that I think that we
owe them an enormous apology for for uh
for for and um uh and we should try to
set it right yeah what you said earlier
I found very interesting but I I would
even in some instances go even further
because you talked about godlessness I
would say there's even elements of just
pure Satanism in our society in our
establishment especially when you look
at people like Jeffrey Epstein when you
look at all the celebrities when you
look at the all the occult stuff the
rappers are doing uh doing um uh Satanic
rituals yeah yeah there's like
sacrifices Lady Gaga leaves a bathtub of
blood in her her tail room but that's a
whole nother topic before even getting
there but but also I I want to talk
about I want to talk about what you said
about institutions because you said
institutions aren't protecting people I
would even go as far as to say that the
institutions are attacking people
especially when it comes to the way of
life especially what they incentivize
and I think it's the institutions that
are a problem so so how do we go back to
that we've given ourselves AIDS so the
white blood cells that should protect us
are attacking us instead exactly so how
do we fix this problem because it seems
like a lot of the the solutions you have
is okay let's let's support Trump let's
let's support these strong institutions
these institutions are corrupted how do
we fix these institutions how do we make
them work for us again America is doomed
without a reversal of the Sedition that
sealed its fate
um which is
American independence
um I'm afraid I'm afraid to say it's all
encoded it sounds like something a
British person would say yes it does
um but there's a reason but there's a
reason I'm here and not there it's
because I like it here better
um and I want America to succeed into
and to win and it would have done so
better as um as a
member of the Commonwealth in good
standing uh it might not have had some
of the uh
remarkable Financial successes uh such
as they are
um you know but but
I can't really imagine in 500 years
people are going to be uh discussing the
Real Housewives of Atlanta
um I don't know that the lasting Legacy
of America is going to be particularly
um valuable compared to other Empires
that have been as Grand as rich and um
as uh as long lasting um somebody wrote
an essay I forget now because I'm old
but um uh as one of your viewers will
know I'm sure about
um polarity and the fact that for a long
time America we lived in a unipolar
world right where America was kind of
the the tentpole
um I think the effect of that has been
unquestionably damn uh damaging and
destructive
um and it might not be such a bad thing
for us to return to a multi-polar
um world with with multiple uh perhaps
competing superpowers
um where there are other visions of of
what a good life looks like I mean Putin
is obviously uh personally uh deeply
unpleasant and maybe maybe even
hideously evil person depending on how
much you believe of what he's supposed
to have done but there's something very
exciting about the way he talks about
cultural issues
um and and it it's wounding when he is
Savage about the failures of the West
because he's right about so much of it
and it's easy to do from there and you
know there's all kinds of Horrors and in
uh in in Russia when you can't even get
your mail delivered without bribing the
mailman I mean it's like practically
that bad I mean Russia is not really a
functioning Society without uh you know
it's like it's like Greece really I mean
anything done at all you need a lot of
cash
um it's it's you know it's all kinds of
problems but but
the the I think I think something that
Russia has preserved that the West
hasn't is um the the high standard of
public discourse the tone of which is
like typically set by the Prime Minister
the president demonic
um when When Vladimir Putin speaks to
the Russian people he does so in Grand
historical terms that nobody in the west
has done for 50 years or more
when you compare it to the the
witless prattle of of most American
presidents in that time the
um pathetic uh uh pandering of most
European leaders
we have become
captives of this feminized discourse
that treats everybody what why what is
the reason for the nanny and culture
this this this uh um intrusive invasive
and destructive uh uh thing it's
feminization of culture that seeks to
seeks to control what everybody says and
everybody doesn't want to say um that's
that's that's you know the primary
problem in America is not race it's
between the Sexes because the Sexes uh
have uh completely failed to fulfill
their
um uh their promise and their
obligations uh men and women now alike
admittedly probably original sin being
men the men's you know a failure of Duty
but men and women are now completely
failing to to perform their rightful
functions and so in the world in a
globalized information economy where
words are powerful
um well that's the arena of women you
know words are a woman's weapon so women
uh wield this kind of like outsized
influence and ability in um social you
know on social media so these become
very very uh heavily policed very
feminine places really fast because
I mean you know the way that men
typically settle things I can't talk
about the podcast is a bit different um
or at least there's a kind of uh um
bubbling underlying ever-present threat
of something else when men are talking
you know um but women use language very
differently and that's what we see now
how everybody talks now I just I'm I'm
so struck by
the way that you know Matthew Arnold
said that everybody no matter where they
come from the working class living in a
trailer they deserve to be exposed to
the very best that has been thought and
and written we we need to go to super
chats you does any questions from that
seems to what Putin is doing our leaders
on the other hand infantilizing us
because they want us dumb independent
yeah uh and we're very close to collapse
we're gonna go to super jets if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com
because we're going to have the
uncensored show coming up at about 11
p.m and uh I I imagine you're not going
to watch I've done well very well have I
been good I've been I've been I've been
just
panic-strickening worst night in my life
a lot of people are I'm having a
terrible time it was a great discussion
we didn't agree I'm glad you like it
because I'm just sitting here hoping
that I I I don't say something Welcome
to our world welcome to my world so uh
let's let's read let's read the Super
Chat Everything Is Right Place some
people you know to be brilliant sorry I
promise I'll be really quick
you know it is it is uh the Christian
way to um reform from within right uh in
other religious Traditions um the the
that's like the blow it blow it up burn
it all down the terrorism is uh um I'm
not just I'm not talking about any well
I'm talking about two specific religions
um terrorism is a is a is a
characteristic of other religions
um historically the Christian way of of
uh of improving fixing things has been
to to um reform from within right uh so
that's for instance what um what
Marjorie does in Congress
um you know she's she's on enemy
territory every day um but she does
their what you do here and I have great
respect for that project I don't mean to
speak disrespectful about it if I did
um because because I know I couldn't do
it
um but uh no it's it's it's it's
everything in its right place you know
um so you're doing what you need to do
over there and and I'm I'm doing what I
need to do
yes all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Mr pool your positivity this morning was
welcomed early water cooler talk was
somber here in PA we were nervous to
start anyways but a win is a win and we
can't fix this mess overnight so gracias
yeah I mean as Milo pointed out many
people wanted a more they wanted revenge
and I think they were they were counting
on it they were counting on it because
they were promised it but they can they
were betrayed they don't got to cry
about having a win though I mean it's
not the one they wanted uh I think I
think it's um I think it's wrong of you
to uh to to trivialize it as as people
being cry babies when they have a uh
justifiable grievance you know you could
say they were being cry babies well you
know you sort of certainly cry about it
in a sort of dismissive way I I received
that as a cry about a win
yeah of course you do because if if if
it's just part of the ordinary pattern
and you know that you have been actively
betrayed by people that you place in
power to look after you you have a
Justified grievance uh you know offense
and outrage are not dirty words they
have been systematically misused by bad
people for a long time but uh when you
have a valid grievance it is right and
proper to feel aggrieved and I don't
think people are crying about it I think
they're Furious and they're right the
metaphor I get is like if you're
gambling on a on a sports ball game and
you're like uh I'll take the Eagles by
16. you need them to win by 16. even
though the Eagles win by three you still
feel like you didn't win even though the
Eagles won yeah the difference is that
um in in our model all the games are
fixed and the coach promised you they do
16.
um that's that's that's that's what
we're living in you know it's not it's
you you it's the in the mafia version of
the sport uh the outcome is
predetermined and you've been promised
an outcome and you've placed a bet on
the basis of that outcome if that
outcome doesn't happen you have been
betrayed and you are right to feel angry
and you are right to seek Vengeance all
right we got rusta who says love the
show was wondering your thoughts on the
theory of companies such as Ford Chevy
and other car manufacturers pulling
Twitter ads in order to hurt Tesla as
Elon used it as collateral in his
purchase of Twitter
I think it's nice that um uh Elon Musk
is is doing a real business instead of
some uh you know sort of uh Outreach of
the state I mean all of his previous all
of his previous businesses have been uh
it is it is still Outreach of the state
the the the government runs numerous bot
accounts for public manipulation and
he's now you're right it is but in in in
specifically in the financial
um uh
and he's always had enormous
um publicly funded cushions
um although to be fair Tesla doesn't
have them while other EV manufacturers
do because tit of Tesla's um carbon
selling yeah this is is the situation is
more complicated than I'm suggesting now
and and um uh and and he doesn't get a
lot of benefits that other people do but
he would never got any of those
businesses off the ground without um
being you know a effectively a kind of
colossal Welfare Queen
um but uh I think it's audacious and
brave and self-sacrificing and I think
that's what people admire about this
um is that it has cost him something to
do this and that's why people like Trump
too and it's another reason that um
DeSantis can't beat him because he's
having hundreds of millions of dollars
poured into his coffers by the worst
people in the world meanwhile Trump's
life is irrevocably wrecked by the
sacrifice that he made to become
president I think people see that I
think people admire that and and with
Elon Musk this is the first time I think
he's done something
um somewhat selfless I want to know who
these individuals are all right we'll
talk about Kevin Griffin uh but let's
read code writer says Milo speaks the
truth so directly correctly in an
apology unapologetically this is why he
was banned this is what we need this is
why we love him thank you
well I'm sorry I'm in retirement but um
uh if well maybe I'm not I don't know I
don't know I don't know if I I don't
know if I I think I would be uh
profoundly miserable trying to operate
in this environment so you will uh you
will have to see me uh now and again in
controlled contexts and dream about what
it might have been like or check out the
uncensored show after all that the live
portion of that one yes Oscar says Milo
I started being political thanks to you
and hearing you speak again makes me
understand why I loved watching you you
summed up how I felt 100 to the T with
your commentary just now on this well
there won't all be compliments well
that's very boring
you won't know this about me but I can't
abide flattery
um uh so yeah um no thank you for being
kind
um I'm responsible for a lot of bad
things in the past uh
um particularly the kind of uh
ugly
um band of imitators at uh turning point
and I've given birth to a lot of ugly
things unwittingly
um I'm trying to make amends for that uh
behind the scenes
um I I hope that by the time I I fall
asleep forever uh that I will have um
left a good impression on uh on on the
world and it'll be slightly better uh at
least that people will smile a little
more
um than uh than the way things were when
I arrived and um I'm taking a reasonable
job so far all right Kyle Miller says as
someone who voted for Trump twice I
think it is time to move on mainstream
media has tainted His Image and now
toxic to voters DeSantis 2024. his
favorability is the same as Hillary
Clinton
it saddens me to see people uh with lack
of faith like that
um and um
I think if you loved Trump you should
remind yourself of why and consider uh
how much you really care about Trump's
being name being toxified by the media
sounds like you have
um capitulated to the enemy narratives
and accepted uh criticisms of trump that
actually don't matter at all uh all that
matters
about Trump is if people love him and
vote for him he will be president
doesn't matter what New York Times
thinks about him they never likes him I
think I think legitimate criticisms
matter because they can make them better
and I think he should have his feet held
to the fire for doing so many wrong
things your closest friends should be
your harshest critics exactly and when
we get into the next bit of the show I
have some things to say about that okay
but but um uh
if you if you abandon the one person who
imperfectly and perhaps disappointingly
at least tried to break up the abusive
stitch up
that is the prevailing
um uh American hegemony
um uh sounds like you've got the country
you deserve mate
all right
peace Scully says I'm a one issue voter
avoiding World War III Trump is the only
politician I am certain would tell NATO
to f off the establishment lining up
around DeSantis wouldn't do so if he has
a hard line with regards to Ukraine
DeSantis will declare war on someone on
day one
um he he is enabled and uh funded and uh
supported by all the same old people who
have done this time and again Trump is
the only President in living memory who
didn't start a new war
right he you know you know there are
things that he I'm really intensely
disappointed with uh about Trump
but one that I can say
um uh in an uncomplicated way I'm
delighted with is that he did not
initiate more widespread needless human
suffering for the benefit not of some
nebulous uh American Democratic project
but really to enrich Walmart
um you know dropping bombs on Riyadh so
that people can drop oxy back home
um just just the the not buying into the
fiction and Corruption of of this
theater that we're presented with this
illusion that we're sold
um and refusing to start a new war is is
maybe the best thing and the most
Christian thing and the most important
thing he did but what he did to Yemen I
think was absolutely disgusting
what did he do he's he was a part of the
Saudi Coalition that was bombing Saudi
Arabia uh that was bomb excuse me Yemen
in favor of the the against the hootsi
rebels working with Al Qaeda
let me let me read this one Stephen
bachmeier says Milo is a good hype man
but not a good convincer of those of us
unconvinced of trump I'm convinced Milo
is paid to talk up Trump the irony of
what he's saying about the Santa
supporters
um so it's um it's been discovered that
people who have a standard deviation
difference in IQ are effectively not
really able to communicate with one
another they sort of talk past each
other
um and and they're sort of like they say
about Britain and America kind of
divided by a Common Language
um so I'm sorry that you're not able to
grasp
um uh what I'm what I'm sort of trying
to express but um uh perhaps that was a
very eloquent way of saying you're dumb
perhaps you'd be happier at the daily
wire I don't know
oh the digs the standard deviation being
10. I'm trying to be nice I don't know
how to be nice he said personal
invective is banned on I don't know any
other way to communicate oh you're doing
a great job that was that was actually
more hurtful the way yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that'll leave a mark uh all
right let's see Christopher says
question for Milo who is the Democratic
nominee in 2024 and how long do you
think realistically until until things
get to how you want them I'm not
optimistic enough to uh believe in a
fetterman presidency
no you know Michael malice was calling
for him I was calling for her too like
weeks ago listen I think America could
could do with taking itself just a
little bit less seriously sometimes
um and these kind of uh um elaborate
codes of behavior that remind me of of
you know Versailles under under the
Louise of all these people orbiting
power except there's nothing in the
middle of it you know at least under
monarchies people were competing for the
favor of the king in America there's
nothing there there's no there there
it's just a flag and then you pick it
and there's you know nothing
a bank
um I I you know I I
sorry what was the question well who do
you think would be the Democratic
nominee so what I was going to say is
you know the Senate is a is a Sinister
and boring Place full of sinister and
boring people
um it should I think reinvent itself
more along the lines of the upper houses
that it was it was founded to imitate uh
and be full of uh quirky eccentrics who
together
in a messy way some you know approximate
the the mood and the spirit of the
nation
um and together kind of Safeguard
against Un-American laws you know um
from from a variety of different quirky
perspectives uh I I think uh Federal is
going to be harmless and I find him
adorable and um frankly I think the more
um people with uh mental um shortcomings
in the Senate the better because
um uh less harm they can do so what
you're saying is people to judge 2024.
no he's he's um he's a different kind of
um Biden fetterman 2024. uh Buddhist is
is is a a particular kind of of um uh of
problem because he's somebody a very
average intelligence
um who cannot be persuaded that he isn't
a genius
um and those people are very dangerous
uh and and because they they are beyond
the reach of of reality and reason uh
they're convinced of their own um uh uh
you know special place in history and um
uh he you know he's
I hope that he will go down as a as a
joke in a footnote and it looks like
that's the case
um but but people who are
maybe even you know not entirely there
because they've gone through something
awful or they've had some kind of a you
know a catastrophic brain injury or
whatever
um there's
I don't mind the idea of a quirky
Committee of National Treasures who
somehow kind of coalesce and protect the
country against itself because although
they're all wacky and weird and and
peculiar somehow the the sum total of
them safeguards what America is
um that's what the House of Lords is
always supposed to be in Britain they
kind of wrecked it now but but that's
what the Senate was supposed to be here
that's what the Senate is modeled on not
this soulless Grim Sinister
um uh
secret Club of backroom dealers
I think the Senate should become more
colorful I think it should have more
personality and if fetterman is the
first step towards that I welcome it all
right Ian King says Tim just bought your
song would love to see you do something
with Independent Artists like Adam
Calhoun Ryan Upchurch or Tom McDonald
all as well as see them on the podcast
I'd love to have them on the podcast
that would be an honor Tom McDonald put
out a new song called fighter it's such
a good song it is a 10 out of 10. it's
one of the best songs I think he's
that's my favorite of all of his songs
and he just put it out I was really
impressed it's good so uh you know I
I've talked to Tom periodically he's an
amazing guy I would love to have him on
the show he's a busy guy and it would be
epic if we were able to put a song
together I don't want to say too much
but uh um keep dreaming and keep
imagining what you think may be
happening but uh you know I'm talking
with Tom we'll see we'll see where it
goes be really cool to have him on the
show and if you say Don't Stop Believing
I'm leaving
Don't Stop Believing restraint I'm too
lazy to get up
all right Rando bunderson says her you I
had to say it after you said that uh
you're right Randall punderson says
heard a lot about Milo but never heard
him speak before is this what d d
character is with 20 Charisma sound like
yes they're all compliments Milo
um I actually understand that
complimentary thank you thank you thank
you um I'd like to point out that you
thought the Santa says low Charisma
because if he was a d d character I
think he has like average oh no he's
like a damp sponge
something clammy and and and unpleasant
that um that you find your hand
accidentally touches uh when you're when
you're when you're when you're thrusting
about for a mug these are way more
hurtful and funnier than direct insults
yeah uh I would agree to disagree
um we have I think we've moved past the
period of uh of debate and uh the mask
of manners and I think we're in uh shut
up stupid you know what uh territory and
culture at the moment
um but we'll talk about that later uh no
I you look um
um
a lot there was a particular group of
people
who were dressing as DeSantis this
Halloween
um women who like women
and it was clear that uh in picking
their outfits they'd only had they'd
merely selected from their own wardrobe
uh and uh it was uncanny and I've never
really been able to see him the same
twice uh you know it's um he's he's
I'm sorry he just seen it and if you
have allowed um Despair and
um uh the demoralization techniques that
you were being pummeled with to um
except
a lesser substitute that cannot possibly
hope to fix the Deep spiritual crisis
that this country is in then I'm sorry
for you but you're part of the problem
so you should just get out of the way
next this layer says wait what Mary
Poppins agreed with the father's virtues
spoonful of sugar was to point out that
rewards can help reinforce the important
but sometimes bitter truth the father
wanted to impart uh except when she no
so she wears a shallow mask of manners
right she presents as
um uh in just the same way that cultural
subversives always do they present as a
functioning member of the prevailing
order but the what she does is is
intensely subversive I mean she she um
she recommends witchcraft as a solution
to um chores right there's a reason that
that um you know humble and unassuming
people consider their daily duties to be
um character forming because they are
they have intuited something that
Aristotle understood which is that
habits become character
and I want to say I agree with you and
disagree with this point A Spoonful of
Sugar implies that you should be
rewarded for doing what you're supposed
to do bribing you for doing what you're
supposed to do anyway with addictive
drug by the way sure right with sugar
listen Sugar's bad when we when we go to
the movie theater
um and we
drench ourselves in fat salt and sugar
and stare at an electric uh uh you know
electric light on the wall we are
hypnotizing ourself in the closest thing
that our society has to a sort of pagan
ritual you probably love it
um
no I'm not I'll pass
um uh you know what was interesting
about that film is screw that CIA
propaganda what was it no so what was
interesting about that that whole series
um which I liked is that they made the
woke guy the villain
um uh he you know he's a bad guy uh and
also that movie is very distinctively
African not black and and I noticed a
lot of American like woke black
activists trying really hard to like it
while also not quite getting it
um and growing up in Europe and I was
surrounded by you know West Indian
Africans Jamaicans and and you know
Nigerians I've been to Africa as most of
the fans of that movie haven't
um and so I was able to you know
appreciate a lot of um what they were
seeking to accomplish in this in this
you know this whatever I'm I noticed
about that film it didn't do the easy
and obvious things right it was very
distinctively African which was a big
risk because American blacks don't know
anything about uh African culture and
Africans are very they have some real
Choice opinions about America such as
Africans from South Africa I'm from
South Africa okay so you understand yeah
um uh so so that was a risk and then
they make the woke guy the the genocidal
villain so I actually didn't know I
actually didn't mind that first movie
and I could see a lot of bad people kind
of uh performing fandom and not really
but also they didn't love it like they
loved end game but um and I I actually
thought the movie was intelligent I I
agree
um uh t'challa the main character wants
closed borders he says if we open up our
borders they'll bring their problems
into our country and we don't want that
we're you know and so and not to mention
it was a patriarchal society where women
weren't allowed to rule and you one year
well they fixed that they fixed that in
the sequel don't worry but you when you
when you roll through combat that's an
offense that cannot be allowed to stand
like Thor who was too masculine for his
own good and had to be turned into a fat
joke let me to reclaim the uh like most
men on TV all right let me read this
next one Douglas Kaplan says
uh Milo have you heard of Frank Turek he
is pretty good explaining evidence for
Christ also Tim it seems people here
near me are getting used to shootings I
was near one today as I was delivering
car parts near Carnegie PA wow crazy I
think that the shootings uh I think your
impression of the uh frequency of
shootings um I mean everybody seems to
notice they're sort of happening a bit
more often the precious reports
selectively as per their their
priorities on on any given day
um I think I mean if I uh if I had to
guess I would imagine that they're
getting more frequent
um uh there's definitely a
pharmaceutical component to that uh um
you know there there are some systemic
uh root causes that all come back to the
things we've been talking about
um mostly fatherlessness
um you know in a in a completely
feminized
um culture uh with a endemic single
motherhood I mean most young men have no
male role models and think about the
think about the people who were crowned
male role models over the last
um 10 years Dylan Mulvaney me I was gay
uh Jordan Peterson a drug addict
um like these are like very very damaged
people in different ways
um which just shows you how desperate uh
you know this age is for Heroes right
um but there are Role Models everywhere
you look they just you just have to work
a bit harder I get so many emails from
women who say how should I vote because
I know I know I know this is outside my
sphere
um and now I just say don't because you
know it's the least you can do after you
know everything either all right um but
but
um the the there was this first part of
his question oh do you know Frank Turek
uh I know the name um I'll I'll check
thank you
makiseina says oh okay I understand my
grandmother was born in 1920 and lived
B100 she always said that the downfall
of this country was giving the woman the
vote had 15 kids never had a career and
said if every woman had her had her life
no one would complain blissfully happy I
bet that she was the happiest woman in
the world uh and um you'd be amazed at
how many grandmothers and it's
specifically grandmothers who have the
benefit of wisdom and are seeing uh
secondary Generations right
um you'd be amazed how many grandmothers
write to me and say you're absolutely
right do you think there's going to be a
Reckoning where these childless
Millennial women are 70 years old
without families that they're gonna I'm
trying to be upset I'm gonna try to
persuade Marjorie to introduce a uh um
friend in need as a friend indeed act
that removes
um the vote from people who are on
antidepressant drugs
um uh just sit back and enjoy the enjoy
the Fallout you know half the Democrat
base should
law that says that um you know to to
care for the most vulnerable in our
society we don't want to expose them to
uh traumatic stressful and triggering um
events like the uh the um high pressure
environment of voting in elections
anxiety if you if you aren't you on
anti-anxiety medication so um you know
if you are one of those people and
you've had a prescription for uh you
know anxiety or depression medication in
the last 12 months we're going to ask
you to sit this election out um that
would be an enjoyable Fallout I'd like
that Maury says this episode is too
based the amount of red pilled truths
being Spoken Here is insane there's a
handful of people who are like wow Tim
Ian and Luke aren't talking and there's
two things I'll say to that one uh what
Milo was saying was interesting to hear
your thoughts articulated as as they
were but also it's been a while since
people have heard for you heard from you
and to hear your kind of uh your your
stance on things you know you have it's
been a long time since you've you've
spoken and here you are speaking for
quite a bit explaining a lot of what
you've seen it feels like you've got to
get a lot a lot off your chest and you
haven't talked in how long oh I'm also
just very rude and I just bang on
forever
um uh but it's interesting most of it's
good materials so people put up with me
uh
um no I'm just not a particularly
cursive Center
um but uh thanks we are going to head
over to the members only show so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button and become a member at
timcast.com click join us sign up we are
going to have a members only show and I
imagine it's going to be very very
interesting because there's a lot that
uh Milo's written so many Post-its these
sort of things that I'm not allowed to
say I don't think you understand I have
been
we'll explain it we'll explain it and
we'll show and then you know what I want
to do I want to actually mail those out
to people those posting this so anyway
well yeah when you see them you'll
you'll it'll it'll do that become a
member at timcast.com and also if you
want to support us in our cultural
Endeavors we release a song it's called
genocide it's available at losing my
mind.com you can buy it on iTunes Amazon
or wherever we were a moment of
uplifting uh mood fix for them well the
song I mean it is in that we mock The
Establishment and we we CG animated a
bunch of journalists to sing words about
how they're evil people it's called
genocide I confess to complete ignorance
about the idiom you operate in because I
I'm uh I I I can't tell songs apart in
that particular genre
um but but perhaps you could perhaps you
could you could give me a smattering
after the show yeah we'll show you and
um if you guys want to support us
tomorrow is the last day for billboard
tracking in the first week and we're
hoping to have a big a bigger impact in
the last song this one's overtly
political so it would be nice to have
some kind of uh jab at The Establishment
making to the charts with your support
uh you can follow the show at timcast
IRL you can follow me at timcast and I
want to make sure I stress I see a lot
of people are becoming members on
YouTube not on YouTube go to timcast.com
there is a we have a private timcast.com
membership we we can't we can't post
these videos on YouTube I see a lot of
people are becoming members on YouTube
so I will stress again not YouTube
membership that's not where the video
will be you see what they've done too
they've put you in the position of a
scolding scolding how dare you money
scolding the viewers who have uh
invested in you the most I just want to
make sure they've done to you no no it's
that people really want to hear hear the
show and if they're getting it from the
wrong spot they're going to be wondering
you're not doing anything I'm just I'm
just I'm I'm stunned by the Injustice
and dysfunction of it we'll talk about
it Milo you want to shout anything out
no no no I I'm quite happy being left
alone any last words of encouragement
I'll go on forever so I'll skip it you
will but it was great and it was
fascinating and a great conversation
thank you so much for coming uh my
YouTube channel is youtube.com forward
slash we are change we don't always
agree I read all the chats and I I love
the debate let's have the conversation I
I made a lot of arguments in my video
today I also talked about what's
happening with Twitter and Facebook
start the conversation let let's build
up the biggest what is it steel man
argument we can and let's get at it uh
youtube.com forward slash we are change
thank you so much for having me actually
it was a small thing um I just wanted to
say thank you for inviting me yeah
um uh which is a um I I was a
a choice out of Step let's say with your
guest booking strategy um of late and
probably not without risk so thank you
for that no problem um I don't think so
I think you're exactly the kind of
person we hope to sit down and talk
about I was in two minds about it
because the lighting in here is so
unflattering but I I did get a fake tan
um impoverished uh imperiling my
recovery from homosexuality uh and we'll
talk about that too uh we should
probably save that yeah uh but um yeah
no I'm thank you for thank you for for
doing it because um thanks for coming
man you have um you have built something
here that um perhaps you can begin to
activate the full potential of
um it's quite exciting so thanks for
having me right on thanks for coming man
that's great uh guys you follow me Ian
Crossing if you want to on the internet
anytime anywhere love you Milo and uh
Luke Tim surge Splurge yes I am at
surge.com everywhere thanks for coming
Milo appreciate it all right don't do
LSD here's what you got to do everybody
right right now right now type into the
top bar timcast.com t-i-m-c as T then
you'll see on the left says join us sign
up to become a member and there's a
whole library of members only shows and
content and at about 11 pm we will
upload the uncensored show with Milo and
you can watch it there I just want to
make sure because a lot of people
signing up for YouTube membership which
which is great I appreciate it but I
want to make sure you know where to
watch the show so pay twice pigs we will
see you all over at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out cheers